ahora vamos entrando en el ecuador de
estos juegos bolivarianos que comanda
colombia con mandan los locales con un
amplio margen sobre venezuela vamos
entonces a valledupar a esta ciudad al
norte del territorio cafetero en donde
comienza el camino hacia parís 2024 allí
se encuentra nuestro enviado especial
louis en mendes gris hoy tuvimos
medallas en 10 deportes que podemos
destacar de esta jornada
así es el juegan como lo mencionas ya
empiezan la segunda mitad por así
decirlo de estos juegos podemos destacar
que se entregaron nuevas preseas y una
de ellas fue en el judo que ya cerró su
competencia por esta decimonovena
edición de los juegos bolivarianos con
la competencia mixta por equipo es una
competencia que recordemos que debutó en
en tokio 2020 y está haciendo lo propio
en esta edición de los juegos
bolivarianos acá en la ciudad de
valledupar la medalla de oro fue para
venezuela que dominó en el último
combate a la representación de perú 4
por 2 el tercer lugar fue para la
representación de república dominicana
pero también hubo ganadores en otros
deportes como es el caso del polo
acuático que se disputó en horas de la
mañana y allí la representación de perú
se colgó el metal dorado en la rama
femenina esto luego de un partido donde
quedaron empatadas con la representación
de venezuela a 13 tantos vale decir
en santa marta 2017 no hubo presencia de
atletas femeninas en esta especialidad
pero sí hubo en el masculino y allí
colombia se hizo con la medalla dorada
que repitió en estos juegos esta vez al
vencer a venezuela con marcador final de
20 por 6 espero una agradable sorpresa
vivieron los habitantes de valledupar el
día de hoy es que la campeona olímpica
mariana pajón se hizo presente en la
ciudad ella va a estar representando a
colombia en la próxima edición ante el
pp y que arrancará el primero de julio y
ya está entrenando en la pista diseñada
en esta localidad compartió con los
pequeños compartió con los habitantes
pero también nos ofreció sus impresiones
recordemos que en tokio había asomado la
posibilidad de continuar en el ciclismo
pero en el ciclismo de pista escuchemos
que nos dieron
siempre ha sido parte de mi
entrenamiento o sea no nunca lo ha
dejado de hacer vamos a ver las
posibilidades ya se habló con el profe
iguales es algo que es de mucho trabajo
y de hacerlo muy responsablemente
entonces estamos ahí todavía dando los
pasos